we're back now on CBS mornings here at 7
30 as Ukraine surveys the damage from
massive Russian attacks all across the
country yesterday officials are saying
at least 19 people were killed many lost
access to power to water to heat in what
was the largest Russian attack in months
we're joined Now by retired lieutenant
general H.R McMaster a CBS News foreign
policy and National Security contributor
also U.S national security adviser
General thank you very much for being
here this is a landmass about the size
of Texas and you can see the scope of
these Russian attacks what stood out to
you well Tony as you mentioned I mean
it's just the scale of it right 84
cruise missiles launched from various
locations about 24 drones some of these
these suicide drones provided to the
Russians by the Iranians and and the the
targets work to terrorize the Ukrainian
people to terrorize them with attacks on
apartment complexes at a school and and
busy intersections uh right at rush hour
but also as you mentioned to attack
infrastructure right to to pose
ukrainians with the prospect of being
cold in the winter right and so all this
was meant to affect Ukrainian will in a
negative way but of course I think it's
had the opposite effect Tony I mean I
think it's bolstered the will of the
ukrainians uh to to you know to fight
for their sovereignty and their freedom
and they have been fighting there's an
attack on a bridge which we're going to
talk to in a second but these Russian
attacks followed a counter-offensive
from Ukraine which what had been having
some success can we talk about that no
yeah we should talk about this and and
it's important because I think the
momentum has shifted uh with this with
this offense and just the guide people
here this is Russian controlled
territory here in the red and the yellow
is where Ukrainian has made Ukraine has
made a push that's right so you have
Russia here you have the Crimean
peninsula here which is really important
a lot of Russian bases established there
after the illegal annexation of Crimea
in 2014 and what you see in the yellow
is a vast amount of territory especially
here in the north uh that has been
retaken in in recent weeks uh by by a
very successful Ukrainian
counter-offensive a counter offensive
that's integrated some some new weapons
capabilities Precision fires in
particular but you know the Russians are
in a really tough spot I mean this is
about and you know at 850 kilometer long
active front and you can't you can't be
strong everywhere yeah so what the
ukrainians did is they determined where
the defenses were weak they penetrated
these defenses and turned the Russians
out of those prepared defenses and made
tremendous gains 1200 kilometer gains
here another consolidating some of those
gains while they continue a smaller
scale offensives but there's a very
strategic area down here in kurzon along
the Juniper River because it's critical
to Russia controlling the Black Sea
Coast and here you have a very
deliberate counter offensive going on
targeting uh some of the some of the the
Russian forces but what's happened
across the front Tony is that the
ukrainians have attacked Supply Depots
and ammunition dumps and so what this
does is it puts a premium on resupply
from Russia and this is really the Kurt
straight Bridge context yeah that why
that mattered so much absolutely so if
you take out if you take out Supply
Depots here and ammunition Depots then
you have to throughput supplies along
extended lines of Supply coming in this
case out of Russia across this Kurt
straight bridge and into some of the key
bases that are on the Crimean peninsula
where they stockpile supplies and then
resupply these forces which are under
increasing pressure from the ukrainians
and so this is the context of the attack
that dropped this bridge here in the
Kurt Strait and that and then you see
this this massive you know retaliation
by the Russians because Putin felt like
he had to do something after what he saw
was a humiliation of this uh this really
great achievement of the ukrainians to
interdict that Supply Route all right
General let's mosey over to the table
because I know Gail and Nate also have
some questions for you we are about six
months into the war here uh and uh this
is the biggest attack we've seen since
the very beginning I know in general you
said the whole purpose is to terrorize
the Ukrainian people you know mission
accomplished what do you make of Putin's
strategy though I attack your country
and then he goes on Russian TV yesterday
and calls the Ukrainian people
terrorists what do you make of the
strategy the Russian people aren't
always getting the truth here no they
never get the truth right I mean
whatever Putin says that the opposite is
reality and uh and I think what you're
seeing now are some real cracks within
within the Russian regime and I think in
Russian popular opinion it's hard to
believe any polls right to come out
right yeah if they say hey what do you
think of Vladimir Putin what are you
going to say right before it just
disappear right yeah if you give the
wrong answer and of course it's
important to note that inside of Russia
now there are more political prisoners
than there were during the height of the
Cold War in the Russian internal
security services more people than there
are in the military and of course what
did Putin tell people hey this is going
to be easy just leave this to me this is
a special military operation yeah it'll
be done quick it'll be done quick yeah
and now they've had tremendous losses
Gail I mean conservative estimates 65
000 casualties right and then and now
he's trying to mobilize 300 000 and
you're seeing that a lot of these he's
mobilizing 300 000 but it's 300 000
people trying to flee the country I mean
they've gone to prisons to recruit you
know 80 80 000 criminals so it's it's
really I think you're seeing the strains
and you know we're talking about these
massive attacks that just occurred how
many more times can they do that I mean
there are reports that they're running
low on ammunition they're buying ammo
from North Korea president President
Biden warned that we haven't been this
close to Armageddon since the Cuban
Missile Crisis yeah how concerned should
we be about a nuclear attack yeah
because that's it just sounds scary when
you use it yeah of course of course it
does Nate and this is all that Putin's
got left right is to Rattle the nuclear
saber and and I think that the
president's you know message was
unfortunate there because it does kind
of play into into Putin's hands that's
right Putin wants to incite fear and he
wants to constrain our support for the
ukrainians who are defending you know
their their children I mean you know
half of the children in Ukraine are
displaced right so this we see this is a
humanitarian catastrophe but it's also
very important from American interests
right I mean you know this is this is
the return of major war to Europe first
time since World War II right and and
and uh you know if Putin gets an off
ramp which some people talk about hey
that's only a chat that's a chance for
him to look for the next on ramp which
has been his pattern of activity since
he took over in the year 2000 right I
mean he's he always conducted massive uh
uh you know cyber attacks and and
disinformation you know to underminer
democracies and of course you know he
invaded Georgia in 2008 invaded Ukraine
2014. this War's been going on since
2014. yeah the world Ukraine isn't an
easy thing to break down we appreciate
you that was a master class from General
McMaster we appreciate it thank you
great to be with you thank you